le plaisir d'accueillir Monsieur Patrick
Lefa vice-président du CPO accompagné de
Monsieur Christophe strassel secrétaire
général du CPO et des magistrats qui ont
présenté ce rapport
votre travail complète celui présenté il
y a deux semaines par la Cour des
comptes sur le financement des
collectivités territoriales donc vous
reprenez d'ailleurs certaines
propositions
c'est peu dire que le sujet du zan est
un sujet d'actualité qui soulève de très
grandes interrogations dans les
collectivités locales vos travaux
susciteront j'en suis sûr un très grand
intérêt dans cette assemblée et je vous
remercie de nous présenter vos
conclusions avant que nous examinions la
première partie de la loi de finances
cette commande faisait suite à un
rapport remis par notre collègue
Jean-Baptiste blanc en juin dernier sur
les outils financiers du zan vos travaux
intéresseront également la mission
conjointe sur le jeûne donc fait partie
notre commission et qui est présidé par
Valérie l'État dans je salue bien sûr la
présence parmi nous ainsi que celle de
Dominique
espositason qui nous rejoindra peut-être
rapporteur pour avis de la commission
des affaires économiques
je rappelle à chacun que cette audition
est ouverte à la presse et retransmise
sur le site internet du Sénat
je vous laisse la parole président Lefa
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président sur le rapporteur
général mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs je dois d'abord
vous prier d'excuser l'absence du
premier président de la du Conseil des
prélèvements obligatoires qui étaient
retenus ce matin vous aviez eu
l'occasion de l'entendre le 12 octobre
dernier en sa qualité de premier
président de la Cour des comptes pour la
présentation des scénarios de
financement des collectivités locales
vous venez de le rappeler monsieur le
Président et il avait pu mesurer lors de
cette audition le vif intérêt que
soulève au sein de votre commission le
sujet du Zéro artificialisation net des
sols le zan qui nous réunit aujourd'hui
je suis venu ce matin comme vous l'avez
rappelé avec
Christophe strassel conseiller maître
secrétaire général du CPO ainsi que les
rapporteurs
des trois rapporteurs madame Claire FAL
extraordinaires et Monsieur David de
carnier conseiller référendaire j'ai
grand plaisir à vous présenter
aujourd'hui les conclusions de l'étude
que vous avez commandé au CPO il y a
plusieurs raisons à cela la première
réside dans le caractère novataire de la
de la procédure par laquelle vous avez
bien voulu saisir le CPO il s'agit vous
venez de le rappeler de la première
utilisation de l'article l331 3 du Code
des juridictions financières qui prévoit
que le CPO peut être saisi pour avis en
vue de d'apprécier les incidences
économiques sociales budgétaire et
financière de toute modification de
législation de la réglementation en
matière d'imposition de toute nature ou
de cotisation sociale les résultats de
ces études et avis sont rendus publics
cette disposition qui a été introduite
par la loi du 6 décembre 2021 est une
nouvelle compétence doublement
ambitieuse
par sa portée sur la formulation des
politiques publiques d'abord puisque
elle permet au CPO d'intervenir en amont
des décisions de politique fiscale et de
prélèvement sociaux afin de les éclairer
et plus seulement comme c'était le cas
jusqu'à présent en aval de ces décisions
pour faire des évaluations
et recommandées des correctifs là nous
sommes bien dans le timing de votre
examen de du PLF et dans la partie
recette
la deuxième ambition c'est en fait les
délais de réalisation des rapports
concernés même si la loi n'impose rien
en termes de de délai la différence par
exemple du 58 2 qui prévoit huit mois
nous avons souhaité pouvoir nous mettre
en situation de répondre à cette saisine
dans un délai de trois mois
compte tenu de du mois d'août ça fait
même sensiblement moins afin d'inscrire
les réflexions du CPO dans le temps de
la décision politique c'est à dire en
l'occurrence
celle de l'examen du PLF par votre Haute
Assemblée nous espérons à l'occasion de
ce premier rapport à tester de l'intérêt
de cette procédure pour éclairer les
choix politiques en matière de
prélèvement obligatoire
la deuxième raison pour laquelle je me
réjouis de d'être devant vous ce matin
vient de ce que le sujet sur lequel vous
avez sollicité l'expertise du CPO
concerne l'environnement dans les années
qui viennent les prélèvements
obligatoires seront mobilisés de plus en
plus souvent pour faire face aux enjeux
liés à la transition énergétique et
climatique dans ce domaine complexe de
la fiscalité environnementale
presque tabou depuis la crise des gilets
jaunes et le casier abandon de la taxe
carbone le CPO souhaite contribuer à la
définition d'une stratégie qui permette
à un infléchissement effectif des
comportements ce qui suppose que les
instruments mis en oeuvre soient à la
fois pertinents sur le plan technique
mais aussi acceptable pour nos
concitoyens et nos entreprises
le rapport que nous vous présentons
aujourd'hui porte sur la fiscalité
locale dans la perspective du zan avec
ces deux jalons que vous connaissez bien
de 2021 à 2031 le rythme
d'artificialisation des espaces naturels
agricoles et forestiers dit Hénaf doit
être divisé par deux par rapport au
rythme de la consommation réelle de ces
espaces observer sur les 10 années
précédentes on pourra revenir
éventuellement sur la quantification de
cette de cet effort d'ici 2050 la France
doit atteindre l'objectif de 0
artificialisation net des sols vous nous
avez fait parvenir la commande de votre
commission par votre lettre du 8 juin
dernier Monsieur le Président comme je
l'indiqué précédemment nous avons
souhaité pouvoir nous fixer dans votre
calendrier pendant cette période une
cinquantaine d'entretiens ont pu être
réalisés par l'équipe des rapporteurs
auprès des différentes parties prenantes
les administrations les collectivités
territoriales organisations
professionnelles entreprises ces
entretiens ont été décisifs pour nous
permettre de faire progresser notre
réflexion puisqu'il n'existe aujourd'hui
que très peu de littérature
administratives et académiques et sujets
beaucoup sur cet aspect là académique
sur le zan qui reste encore un sujet
très neuf y compris d'ailleurs il faut
le dire dans les autres pays européens
puisque la littérature académique n'est
pas plus présente chez nos partenaires
européens
nous avons souhaité rester au plus près
de vos préoccupations en organisant
plusieurs temps d'échanges avec votre
apporteur général et monsieur le
sénateur blanc que je remercie pour leur
disponibilité les réponses attendues du
CPO portaient essentiellement sur deux
questions la première c'est est-ce que
l'objectif zan va modifier les
équilibres financiers des collectivités
territoriales et des groupements et si
oui quelles ajustements peuvent être
envisagées deuxième question la
fiscalité locale peut-elle envoyer un
signal prix aux acteurs économiques pour
faciliter l'atteinte de l'objectif zan
et si oui quelle modification doivent
être apportées nos réponses à ces deux
questions sont séquencés dans le temps
et distingue les mesures qui peuvent
être envisagées à court terme et celles
qui concerne des évolutions à moyen et
long terme
en termes de périmètre notre étude
apportée sur les prélèvements fiscaux
locaux les plus susceptibles de jouer un
rôle de notre point de vue dans les
comportements d'artificialisation des
sols les taxe foncières bien sûr
la cotisation
foncière des entreprises la taxe
d'aménagement les droits de mutation à
titre onéreux la taxe d'habitation sur
les logements vacants la taxe
d'habitation sur les résidences
secondaires la taxe sur les frisses
commerciales et les taxes spéciales
d'équipement serait périmètre
représenterait en 2021 et vous l'avez
sur le tableau quelques 65 milliards de
recettes soit un peu plus du tiers de
l'ensemble des impositions de toute
nature affectées aux collectivités
locales ou collectées par elles nous
avons exclu la taxe sur les surfaces
commerciales la TASCOM parce que un
rapport d'information de la commission
des affaires économiques du Sénat avait
fait un tour très complet du sujet en
liaison avec les parties prenantes
partons de ce périmètre de prélèvement
notre réflexion aboutit à trois messages
principaux le premier
est que la fiscalité locale n'est pas
responsable à titre principal de
l'artificialisation mais peu devenir un
outil plus efficace au service de
l'objectif zen
deuxièmement un changement de paradigme
pour adapter la fiscalité locale aux
ânes et souhaitable troisièmement des
travaux complémentaires sont nécessaires
avant de conférer un rôle plus important
à la fiscalité locale dans la mise en
œuvre d'usage
s'agissons tout d'abord du premier
constat il nous semble important de
souligner avec force que la fiscalité
locale telle qu'elle se présente
aujourd'hui est un déterminant très
marginal dans les décisions qui
conduisent artificialiser artificialiser
les sols un rapport conjoint de l'INRA
et de lipstar qui constituent la
principale Annie analyse fiable à cet
égard aboutit sans ambiguïté à cette
conclusion il montre notamment que le
poids économique de la fiscalité locale
qui représente par exemple 5% des
charges dans une opération immobilière
ne peut avoir pour effet d'influencer de
manière significative les décisions
d'artificialisation à l'inverse la
fiscalité locale n'incite pas davantage
à lutter contre l'artificialisation des
sols il n'y en effet dans notre panoplie
fiscal aucun instrument qui aurait pour
effet d'inciter à la renaturalisation
des sols ou encore à la conservation en
l'état d'une parcelle artificialisé
de ses premiers constats le CPO tire une
première série de recommandations
tendant à mettre en œuvre des
dispositifs fiscaux ciblés favorables à
l'objectif Zam les deux premières
recommandations sont les suivantes
d'abord supprimer le critère du nombre
d'habitants qui est fixé actuellement à
50000 pour la taxe sur les logements
vacants tout en conservant le critère de
tension sur le marché immobilier la
suppression du critère du nombre
d'habitants est également proposé pour
la majoration de la taxe d'habitation
sur les résidences secondaires en
deuxième lieu il est proposé de
fusionner les deux taxes sur les
logements vacants en une taxe unique qui
serait transformée en impôts locales
une troisième recommandation vise à
mieux sensibiliser les collectivités
locales aux outils existants pour lutter
contre l'artificialisation ces outils
restants souvent d'ailleurs mal connues
et en définitive peut utiliser
lorsqu'ils existent pour cela il est
proposé d'inscrire à l'ordre du jour des
assemblées municipales et communautaires
dans le cadre du rapport triennal sur
l'artificialisation des sols un débat
portant sur le recours aux instruments
fiscaux concourant à l'objectif d'ARN
une quatrième recommandation
porte sur les exonérations et abattement
appliqués à la fiscalité locale qui
devrait être mise en cohérence avec
l'objectif zan en étant réservé aux
opérations non artificialisantes plus
précisément le CPO recommande de
réserver les zones exonérations de taxes
locales aux opérations sur zone déjà
artifici en particulier les opérations
de recyclage urbain
toutes les mesures qui viennent d'être
énumérées présentent comme
caractéristiques de pouvoir être mis en
œuvre selon
notre appréciation
en rapidement
dans un deuxième temps de notre
réflexion
nous nous sommes
attachés à proposer des orientations à
plus long terme c'était évidemment le
sens de votre commande la logique
générale de ces recommandations et de
taxer pour les mutualiser les rendent
qui seront engendrées par un foncier
devenu plus rare ainsi du fait de la
mise en oeuvre de l'objectif zan le prix
des terrains nus devenus constructibles
risquent d'augmenter dans des
proportions importantes c'est pourquoi
le CPO propose d'augmenter le taux de la
taxe sur les plus-values de cession de
terrain nu rendus constructible et
d'envisager la suppression de la clause
dite des 18 ans au-delà de laquelle ces
plus-values sont aujourd'hui exonérées
le CPO a par ailleurs considéré que le
âne allait entraîner des différences
importantes dans la dynamique des
recettes foncières des collectivités
locales en effet ce sont non seulement
les taxes foncières qui vont évoluer
différemment en fonction de la
répartition des espaces constructifs sur
le territoire mais aussi la deuxième
globale de fonctionnement qui est
aujourd'hui directement corrélée au
développement des communes comme vous le
savez pour les communes éligibles
environ 4200 2021 la DGF est déterminée
en fonction du potentiel financier de
l'effort fiscal de la population d'autre
part et du classement en zone de
revitalisation rurale lequel major de
30% l'attribution perçue en conséquence
le CPO attire dès à présent la tension
sur la nécessité d'intégrer les effets
du zan dans les mécanismes de solidarité
horizontaux et verticaux à destination
des collect et de leur groupement
dans le même esprit le CPO recommande
d'intégrer les conséquences du zan dans
la réflexion en cours sur la refonte du
système de financement des collectivités
locales ainsi il est proposé
d'envisager l'affectation des droits de
mutation à titre onéreux au bloc
communal comme la cour la proposée dans
le rapport qui vous a été présenté il y
a 15 jours et d'étudier la pertinence
des taux variables de DMTO en fonction
du caractère artificialisé
artificialisant pardon des opérations
immobilières il est proposé également
d'intégrer les conséquences du zan dans
les projections réalisées pour la
réforme des bases locatives cadastrales
et d'envisager des mesures de correction
ou de compensation si les résultats vont
dans un sens contraire à l'objectif
voilà pour le deuxième temps de notre
réflexion dans un troisième temps
nous avons exploré les sujets sur
lesquels il nous semblait que des
travaux complémentaires étaient
nécessaires avant de pouvoir donner un
rôle plus important à la fiscalité
locale dans la mise en œuvre aux usages
en premier lieu
un chiffrage des impacts financiers du
zan pour l'ensemble des parties
prenantes collectivités états
entreprises ménage reste à réaliser pour
le moment on dispose d'une seule étude
qui a été financée par la Fédération
Nationale des Travaux publics dans le
cabinet est réalisé par le cabinet
carbone 4 qui chiffre le coût de
réhabilitation des friches commerciales
dans une fourchette quand même très
large comprise entre 77 et 106 milliards
d'euros c'est intéressant mais
évidemment beaucoup trop partiel c'est
pourquoi le CPO insiste sur la nécessité
de de ce travail de chiffrage qui
devrait être confiée aux administrations
compétentes qui seraient également
chargées d'identifier les pistes de
financement de ses coûts
par ailleurs en l'absence d'un tel
chiffrage le CPO a considéré que toute
réflexion sur une taxe zan serait très
prématurée en revanche il recommande
d'étudier l'extension de la couverture
géographique des établissements fonciers
à l'ensemble du territoire national cela
concerne deux régions encore qui n'en
ont pas Bourgogne Franche-Comté et
centre Val de Loire ainsi que celle de
la taxe spéciale d'équipement affectée à
leur financement enfin le CPO recommande
d'étudier la pertinence d'un système de
bonus malus dans le calcul de la taxe
d'aménagement pour favoriser les
opérations de dépollution ou de
réaménagement est taxé davantage les
opérations artificialisantes
le chemin qui reste à parcourir pour
mettre en cohérence la fiscalité locale
et l'objectif zan et donc encore long le
CPO ne prétendait pas dans le délai qui
lui était un parti traiter l'ensemble
des conséquences du sujet qui supposent
à n'importe en travail de documentation
notamment en matière d'analyse
économique économétrique de la part des
administrations compétentes et des
chercheurs avec l'aide des secteurs
économiques les plus directement
concernés qui doivent s'emparer du sujet
le CPO reste à la disposition du Sénat
bien sûr pour approfondir tel ou tel
aspect du présent rapport il ne
s'interdit pas pour sa part d'y revenir
de sa propre initiative dans un proche
avenir dans les enjeux qui sous-tendent
cette question sont importants et encore
largement inexplorées malgré l'urgence
climatique je vous remercie pour votre
attention et me tient à la votre
disposition avec le secrétaire général
du CPO les rapporteurs pour répondre à
vos questions
merci merci monsieur le président
merci pour ce travail et merci pour la
qualité de la restitution comme
d'habitude à la fois complète et
synthétique
je vais donner la parole donc à
Jean-Baptiste blanc tout d'abord notre
rapporteur spécial
merci monsieur le Président
Valérie Létard ensuite peut-être
voilà au titre de la mission ce qui
effectivement c'est un travail conjoint
que nous menons
et qui nous mobilise fortement alors
déjà monsieur le Président merci de me
donner la parole pour réagir cette
présentation importante pour cette
commission
des finances sur ce sujet du zan qui
nous préoccupe absolument tous vous avez
accepté monsieur le Président Daval
rapporteur général de saisir le CPO
sur ce sujet et j'en profite pour vous
remercier de nouveau ce travail a le CPO
a été de très grande qualité permet de
vous dire Monsieur le Président et de
vous en remercier
aussi on s'est vu à de nombreuses
reprises on a échanger souvent et c'est
très heureux parce qu'effectivement vous
l'avez dit il y a il n'y a pas de
littérature sur le sujet tout est à
construire et c'est ce que nous essayons
de faire ici au Sénat d'où d'ailleurs
cette mission conjointe de contrôle donc
présidée par validité qui se tient en ce
moment enfin qui tient ses travaux en ce
moment qui va rendre sa copie aussi dans
les prochaines semaines et croyez bien
que ce volet là qu'elle voit du CPO est
très attendue aussi ce rapport sera
joint au nôtres puisque en marge de tous
nos sujets zan qui inquiète ou
interrogent absolument tous les élus
locaux de tout bord de tout territoire
il y a évidemment un toile de fond le
modèle économique du zan sont
financement et les perspectives d'une
nouvelle fiscalité locale et
éventuellement alors en effet vous ne
pouviez pas proposer un grand soir de la
fiscalité locale en deux mois mais force
est de constater et je vous en remercie
vous proposez de très nombreuses pistes
tout de suite à utiliser sur sur ce
sujet d'ailleurs vous le signalez
d'emblée dans ce rapport il y a
déjà des taxes existantes dont on part
assez peu les élus locaux et c'est assez
étonnant peut-être qu'il peut y avoir
une démarche en ce sens vous proposez
d'ailleurs de faire des conférences sur
le sujet enfin des réunions bilandières
il y a un bilan de consommation du
foncier à faire tous les trois ans
peut-être qu'on pourrait adosser ça mais
enfin en tout cas nausées
existants et c'est dommage
puisque on est tous d'accord peut-être
sur le fait que
désormais il faut fiscaliser ce sujet
trouver un rendement fiscal en tout cas
la récompenser la vertu je vais venir
sur ce point
après parce que nous sommes un moment
important de notre histoire de la
fiscalité locale me semble-t-il au
moment où elle disparaît peut-être
qu'elle peut être repensée mais bon je
disais voilà il y a ce qui peut être
utilisé tout de suite il y a ceux qui
peut être toiletté tout de suite vous
proposer de très nombreuses pistes aussi
si j'ai 30 secondes aussi en évoquera un
ou deux exemples sur le sur le sujet et
vous proposez aussi
intéressante plus prospective sur la
suite de l'histoire faut-il un imposable
faut-il une taxe Zane
peut-être qu'il va falloir cheminer vers
ça alors sans en créer
de nouveau d'impôts de taxes qui
chacun partage ça ce qui nous
semble-t-il et
en tout cas il y a un système fiscal qui
est
peut-être trop trop important et
attentifs qu'il faut stabiliser mais on
peut peut-être toiletter des assiettes
et puis vous
évoquez aussi le sujet tout aussi
important de la redistribution ce qu'il
y aura des perdants du zan
malheureusement donc les péréquations
horizontales et verticales en
particulier et voilà alors
beaucoup de matières que nous pourrons
nous pourrions utiliser dès le prochain
projet de loi de finance en effet dès
les prochains projets de la finance dans
la foulée
et de manière plus prospective ensuite
progresser via le Sénat d'ailleurs ce
sujet est suivi désormais semble-t-il de
près par le gouvernement c'est heureux
puisque c'est ici au Sénat que nous
avons sonné un peu cette révolte là d'un
texte voté vite dont nous avons souhaité
qu'il soit territorialisé dans son
approche pour éviter une démarche
beaucoup trop descendante une démarche
que nous voulons ascendante c'est en
partant des îles locaux des scottes et
des droits de proposition on arrive à ce
moment-là de l'histoire où nos élus
dépose des propositions dans chaque
région via leur Scott les régions vont
prendre le relais sont en train de
prendre le relais pour discuter de ses
propositions dans la perspective de la
mise en révision de leur stradette et
c'est ça qui nous interroge donc c'est à
dire avant nous assez de temps assez
d'ingénierie voilà pas forcément et
votre rapport va nous aider vous
signaler par exemple que
les villes moyennes dans et leur dans
leur pér notamment et la ruralité manque
d'ingénierie et d'accompagnement sur le
sujet et que des réponses juridiques
doivent être trouvées par la loi va voir
mais par les finances et la fiscalité
sans doute merci de nous rappeler
évidemment cette chose très attendue ici
concernant les villes moyennes et la
ruralité
une petite frustration mais vous avez
répondu c'est il faudra faire d'autres
études pour envoyer à des travaux sur la
TASCOM on aurait aimé en savoir plus
néanmoins mais enfin on va on va on va
s'y pencher et puis sur le modèle
économique du zan on a au produit une
étude et il en faudra sans doute
d'autres pour savoir combien ça coûte
exactement
et de quoi nous parlons en particulier
ou produits des chiffres concernant les
friches industrielles qui sont très
importants puisque on sait pas à quel
Saint se Brou et est-ce que ce qui nous
est proposé en matière de fonds friche
qui devient fond vert et suffisant pour
répondre à l'enjeu véritablement
apparemment pas vraiment si on veut être
plus ambitieux va falloir mobiliser des
sommes beaucoup plus importantes
et donc elle reste savoir lesquelles
bien entendu voilà alors si j'ai encore
une minute monsieur le Président
évoquer ce qui me paraît
très important dans les dispositifs
fiscaux ciblés qu'on pourrait mettre en
oeuvre assez rapidement il y a
effectivement tout ce qui est destiné à
limiter la vacance et réguler les
résidence secondaire avec des
propositions assez simples et rapides à
mettre en oeuvre la suppression d'un
critère de 50 000 habitants notamment ça
me paraît simple et intéressant inciter
la densification
urbaine alors et s'étonner je partage
votre retournement sur la suppression du
du VSD enfin le versement pour sous
densité pourquoi ça a été supprimé l'an
dernier alors certes peut utiliser cette
possibilité mais
paraît intéressant de la remettre au
goût du jour assez rapidement et que nos
élus effectivement
puisse utiliser les outils et puis une
réflexion sur les exonérations
les exonérations et les abattements à la
fiscalité locale c'est effectivement une
grande réflexion qu'on a toujours avec
cette
difficulté de savoir quel quel
exonération
à quelle niche fiscale touchée
exactement parce que ce sujet sensible
on le sait mais
effectivement supprimer les niches
artificialisantes ça me paraît très
intéressant je vais pas reprendre toute
la liste elle est très complète et elle
va nous être très utile et puis après
donc il y a ce qu'on peut toiletter tout
de suite ce qu'on peut s'emparer tout de
suite et puis il y a ce qui est plus
prospectif et dans ce qui est plus
prospectif je crois quand même je sais
pas si mes collègues partageont ça que
on peut quand même considérer que le la
fiscalité est un outil pour modifier les
comportements et pour en finir avec
certaines rentes qui n'ont manqueront
pas de de s'alourdir ou s'aggraver avec
avec sésame la fiscalité pour moi
modifie les les comportements d'ailleurs
je suis pas tout à fait d'accord avec
vous déjà échanger c'est le seul petit
point de d'accord maintenant il est très
léger c'est sur le caractère artificiel
zéro pas de la fiscalité je crois quand
même qu'on était dans un pays qui
s'étalait et que cet étalement a
[Musique]
nécessairement
de l'artificialisation et de la
fiscalité donc la fiscalité par votre
conséquence
peut être considéré comme artificialiser
vous le signalez il y a le foncier il y
a tout un tas de critères qui sont pris
en compte par les opérateurs mais quand
même voilà alors voilà la réflexion plus
prospective est-ce qu'on doit taxer la
rente le comportement pour pour moi oui
en tout cas ouvrir le sujet en tout cas
parce que ce foncier qui va devenir plus
rare plus cher nécessairement on va
appelle à nous faire appel à réagir sur
le sujet la la redistribution bien
entendu et vous évoquez aussi ces
dotations de l'État qui sont peut-être
artificialisantes de façon sans doute et
qui doit être revu
aussi et puis
tenir compte de des écarts de potentiel
fiscal pour le futur avec Valérie l'état
parmi nos sujets il y a ceux de
qui consiste à se demander si on a assez
peu en compte les spécificités de
littoral de la montagne de la ruralité
des petites villes toutes les outre-mer
bien entendu voilà et qui sont ou le
signaler aussi de l'autre côté ça nous
conforte dans nos analyses restreints
dans les capacités d'aménagement et donc
possiblement puni dans les possibilités
de rendement pour financer le Lausanne
voilà alors les dotations sans doute
peut-être revu aussi et à ce sujet
merci de signaler une dotation que je
connaissais pas la dotation budgétaire
pour le soutien aux communes pour la
protection de la biodiversité et la
valorisation des aménitaires rurales
voilà alors cher Valery les aménités
rurales je crois
ça va nous inspirer pour les conclusions
mais voilà effectivement le d'autant le
potentiel fiscal va être un énorme sujet
à avoir et les rééquilibres nécessaires
des des critères des péréquations pour
qu'il n'y ait pas de perdant du zan
voilà en tout état de cause voilà
prendre en compte le la rente les
revenus la valeur créée
sanctionner le comportement
artificialisant
pensez aux liens fiscal trouver de
nouveaux gisements fiscaux pour nos élus
locaux qui n'en ont plus beaucoup et qui
n'ont plus beaucoup d'autonomie
financière par voie de conséquence
peut-être se mettre en conformité aussi
en ce qui concerne la révision des
valeurs locatives cadastrales vous le
signalez et merci infiniment c'est très
précieux et au final effectivement on se
posera la question de savoir s'il faut
un impôt ou une taxe ZAD voilà alors
peut-être que la suppression programmée
de la CVAE aurait pu servir à ça aussi
mais les DMTO c'est une piste
effectivement extrêmement intéressante
et importante la cour la signaler ici
pas votre premier président assez
récemment
vous le reprenez à nouveau il faut qu'on
y réfléchisse qu'on s'y penche notamment
les DMTO si le bloc communal les
récupérer ça change absolument tout dans
notre histoire pardon et
il pourrait y avoir voler additionnel
assez DMTO
en effet ou alors est-ce que c'est la
taxe d'aménagement qui peut suffire
envisager une suite de notre histoire
voilà alors voilà monsieur le Président
le ce que ça m'inspire à ce stade oui
mais enfin comme nous sommes
je l'ai bien noté
spécial
donner la parole je voudrais dire pour
ma part que
je suis très heureux que la Commission
est posée mandatée sur ce sujet
parce que nous
avions
vous imaginions bien qu'il y avait des
sujets à regarder mais votre rapport de
ce matin
nous montre que c'est une vision très
large qu'il faut avoir sur le sujet que
l'on peut déjà approcher comme cela a
été fait excellent par Jean-Baptiste
blanc un certain nombre de sujets qui
peuvent être assez rapidement mis en
oeuvre en tout cas faire l'objet de
préconisations assez rapidement d'autres
vous l'avez noté nécessite des travaux
complémentaires c'est une évidence mais
de manière générale
on retrouve là sur ce dossier comme sur
beaucoup d'autres finalement notre
incapacité à travailler dans le bon
ordre c'est-à-dire que
on vote des textes on travaille sur des
projets de loi et après se rend compte
que toute la base qui aurait dû être
faite avant
n'est pas faite n'est pas réalisé et que
finalement ce rapport on devrait l'avoir
on aurait dû la voir avant même le
projet de loi et c'est vrai en matière
fiscale et c'est vrai sur d'autres
d'autres aspects de ce de ce projet de
loi qui aurait nécessité des études
préalables un peu plus longues avant de
délibérer sur un texte
nous le savons aussi avec
les suppressions d'impôts que ce soit la
TH qui a nécessité que ce soit pour
partir de loin pour pas
parler de ce gouvernement spécifiquement
parce que je vois des regards je vois
des regards pas beaucoup et donc je
voudrais pas spécifier mais dire bon si
on revient sur la taxe professionnelle
c'est assez loin c'est assez loin et
tout va bien il a fallu jamais que trois
ans ou 4 pour après remettre les choses
en ordre et faire en sorte que ça
fonctionne je dis pas en or ça et sur le
zan on sent que c'est à peu près la même
chose c'est-à-dire que il y a un texte
de base qui est décrit derrière tout ça
ne correspond pas et puis on réfléchit
après finalement aux éléments qui aurait
dû être amenés sur la table par le
gouvernement dès le début bien donc nous
sommes heureux au Sénat de rattraper ces
choses-là pour ce domaine-là et je suis
heureux que la commission des finances
fasse cet apport à la mission conjointe
sur Lausanne et je ne parle bien sûr à
Valérie l'État pour nous dire comment
comment un intègre ce qu'elle vient
d'entendre
ben écoutez monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Rapporteur général bien sûr
je salue mon collègue Jean-Baptiste
blanc qui est rapporteur spécial dans la
commission des finances et notre
rapporteur de la mission commune de
contrôle et au combien c'est essentiel
pour le Sénat d'avoir
Jean-Baptiste avec cette double mission
qui est la sienne et qui est absolument
essentielle dans l'exercice que le Sénat
doit rendre
mes chers collègues et monsieur le
Président du du Conseil des prélèvements
obligatoires merci beaucoup
de cet éclairage que vous devez que nous
que vous venez de nous donner et bien
sûr monsieur le Président vous l'avez
rappelé monsieur le rapporteur
c'est particulièrement
utile aux travaux du Cénac d'avoir eu
cette initiative monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Rapporteur
comme la constaté aussi Jean-Baptiste
lors de ces travaux précurseurs sur le
sujet et comme nous l'avons aussi
constaté dans le cadre des travaux de la
mission commune de contrôle le Sénat est
très attendu sur les solutions que nous
apporterons à la fiscalité et au
financement du Zen la demande de la
commission des finances elle est
essentielle comme vous l'avez dit
monsieur le Président c'est peut-être
pas dans le bon ordre qu'elle est
arrivée et il aurait fallu effectivement
que l'initiative gouvernementale et que
le Sénat ait pu il aurait fallu qu'il
puisse être saisi en tout cas qu'il
puisse se mobiliser dans un premier
temps en réaction à des propositions qui
devaient être en amont vous l'avez dit
et d'ailleurs
notre rapporteur n'a pas manqué non plus
de signifier et nos auditions nous ont
bien montré aussi que et bien les études
d'impact étaient malheureusement bien
trop muettes sur bon nombre d'aspects
qui traitent de la question du Zéro
artificialisation nette ce qui n'aide
personne dans la bonne prise en compte
effectivement des conséquences que cela
peut avoir
notre mission de contrôle elle a
identifié trois enjeux je les pose tout
simplement en écho de ce que monsieur le
Président devient de nous présenter et
qui sont absolument centraux et sur
lequel il nous faut apporter des
solutions à court terme un moyen long
terme vous l'avez rappelé c'est évident
d'abord les effets ce qui concerne les
effets de bord de la fiscalité au regard
d'usane qui sont comme vous l'avez
rappelé origine originellement conçu
pour d'autres fins comme encourager la
construction de logements ou taxer la
détention de fonciers valoriser grâce au
bâti nos impôts et taxes ne sont plus
forcément adaptés à nos enjeux de
transition environnementale du 21e
siècle à tout le mois il faut les
repenser globalement c'est quelque chose
qui fait consensus en tout cas qui était
un des points font enfin de base posée
par
la mission commune de contrôle et qui
revient sur tout ce que nous entendons
le deuxième c'est qu'il faut dégager des
nouveaux moyens pour financer l'action
de l'État et surtout les collectivités
pour financer Lausanne en s'oriente
évidemment vers des opération recyclage
foncier bien plus coûteuse que la
construction nouvelle simple et des
coups de mise en réserve foncière qui
vont augmenter vous l'avez rappelé avec
ces nouveaux équilibres quelle
ressources nouvelles prévoit-on pour la
fiscalité locale
troisièmement et cet aspect nous paraît
fondamental c'est comment allons-nous
aborder les effets redistributifs
d'usane certains Français vont voir leur
terrain perdre fortement en valeur
lorsqu'il deviendront un constructible
d'autres vont beaucoup gagner sans
action aucune grâce à l'os des prix du
foncier voir la spéculation dans
l'intérêt général et dans un objectif
d'équité comment allons-nous modérer ses
effets sur le patrimoine et sur les prix
c'est vraiment ça les trois postulats en
tout cas qui animent nos auditions notre
mission est sur lesquelles évidemment
votre rapport
enfin voilà amène déjà des propositions
extrêmement concrètes monsieur le
rapporteur vient de balayer
effectivement
toute une série de sujets sur pour
lesquelles des choses peuvent se faire
rapidement monsieur le Président vous y
avez répondu en écho il est extrêmement
important que nous regardions avec
attention
et de façon en tout cas rythmée et sans
confond de vitesse et précipitation
parce que les sujets que vous évoquez
enfin on les connaît tous on le sait
bien que ce soit les DMTO par exemple
pour citer un exemple très concret on
voit bien quel débat quels inquiétudes
ça peut susciter à chaque fois qu'on va
aborder un sujet une fiscalité quels en
sont les conséquences il y a des sujets
qui sont simples et sur lesquels nous
pouvons avancer rapidement monsieur le
rapporteur l'a dit d'autres sur lequel
il faut mesurer effectivement l'impact
les conséquences de chacune des
décisions et des propositions que nous
ferons c'est essentiel la réussite Duane
passera par la capacité et les moyens
que nous mettrons à trouver des
solutions pour encourager à la
mobilisation du foncier mais en même
temps attention de rester juste
équitable il y a des inquiétudes des
mères sur le terrain il y a des
inquiétudes de nos concitoyens qui vont
parce que nos concitoyens n'ont pas
encore compris n'ont pas encore mesuré
les conséquences que ça allait avoir sur
leur réalité et ça il faut aussi bien
l'anticiper parce que pour l'instant on
en est pas encore arrivé à ce stade là
de la prise en connaissance et en fin
voilà de la réalité de ce que va
représenter l'application de ce zéro
artificialisation net il faut le réussir
et ce travail que vous menez dans la
commission des finances il est majeur
merci monsieur le Président merci
monsieur le rapporteur pour l'expertise
incroyable que vous amenez à cette
mission
merci Madame le présidente monsieur le
rapporteur général oui merci monsieur le
Président moi je veux remercier
évidemment les auteurs des travaux
donc les félicités comme l'a fait notre
collègue
Jean-Baptiste blanc mais le président et
je crois que tout le monde partage
ce travail dont on mesure
finalement j'ai entendu le notre
président
regretté des problèmes de méthodes moi
je sais pas si France nation verte qui
annonce à nouveau une nouvelle méthode
sera
utile moi je crois au moins autant au
pragmatisme de notre assemblée
voter le zéro artificialisation nette ça
fait bien dans le décor et quand on le
met en oeuvre c'est beaucoup plus
complexe donc si on peut remettre les
choses dans le bon ordre et avec méthode
discernement patience dialogue
construire des solutions
vraiment c'est préférable deuxième
élément pour reprendre dans les propos
du président dans son propre objectif on
a quand même un sujet majeur
certains l'ont dit c'est toujours bien
de supprimer des taxes et impôts
mais quand on les remplace pas rien que
les nations de l'État c'est-à-dire que
c'est une autre manière d'utiliser
l'impôt on déresponsabilise on appauvrit
et on crée plus de mécontents que de
satisfait puisque finalement ça
contourne un salon de contraintes donc
je pense que le sujet de la fiscalité
environnementale est un sujet majeur il
a il faut c'est pas parce qu'il a échoué
avec la tâche carbone pour des
conditions des raisons assez évidentes
que personnellement j'avais même assez
vite identifié en amont mais passons
c'est pas parce que on a échoué qu'il
faut pas remettre le sujet au cœur de
nos débats
parce qu'il est au cœur de nos débats de
la même manière que nos concitoyens
certains ont des mais comment va faire
dans la situation actuelle qui va finir
par payer elle va sur des sujets comme
ça je pense que le Sénat les travaux le
fait d'aller demander une expertise
parce que vous êtes pour une assemblée
comme la nôtre finalement aussi un tiers
expert un tiers de confiance et je crois
que c'est par cette méthode qui va
consister à
rassembler des points de vue des
expertises pour construire des débats où
il y aura des accords des lignes
directrices
où il faudra obtenir compte des demandes
assez diverses de tous les territoires
je pense que c'est la méthode alors ça
met parfois un peu plus de temps
mais le souhait qui est le mien et
notamment enfin j'espère le nôtre et on
le voit
Valérie Létard l'a dit c'est un travail
parce que je crois qu'effectivement il
faut pas se cacher derrière et au
contraire moi je ressens une fierté
d'avoir fait le choix parce que c'est
dans nos compétences mais bien au-delà
parce que c'est le cœur du sujet de
mettre le sujet de recherche de
modalités fiscale et financière pour
trouver un point d'équilibre et faire
que le dispositif puisse tourner
c'est attendu en fait par tout le monde
c'est pas parce que c'est pas le sujet
pour lequel peut-être beaucoup ont de la
pétance mais en fait pour que ça
fonctionne il faut trouver ces modalités
pratiques donc vraiment je voulais
remercier les uns les autres moi j'ai
juste je dirais deux questions la
première sur
votre proposition qui consisterait à
définir des taux variables de DMTO donc
en fonction du caractère
artificialisation artificialisant des
opérations immobilières est-ce que vous
avez
identifié des des travaux existants qui
permettraient
d'approfondir cette piste
et notamment peut-être
est-ce que vous avez en l'état actuel de
vos travaux et réflexions des des
éléments des premiers éléments qui
pourrait nous être fournis sur la
question des niveaux de densité là
encore je le dis sachant qu'il faudrait
que ce soit
adapté un peu aux situations locales et
territoriales donc
à la fois universel
et des déclinaisons territoriales et
deuxième et dernière question
dans les dans le travail que vous avez
fait sur le terrain et vous avez eu
l'occasion de nous dire dans des temps
d'échanges intermédiaires que vous aviez
des des remontées est-ce que dans le
même temps de la réflexion que
conduisent les collectivités vous avez
identifié à des travaux menés par les
l'administration centrale sur
la prise en compte de la problématique
zan dans la fiscalité éventuellement
d'ailleurs dans la fiscalité locale
parce que j'observe que à ce stade par
exemple dans les lois de finances dans
les dans le même dans le PDF qui arrive
je ne vois de la part de l'État pas
grand chose
c'est le président ce que je vous
propose de réagir rapidement
de Jean-François Husson du rapporteur
spécial de Valérie Létard très
rapidement merci merci beaucoup monsieur
le Président oui je commence peut-être
par le par la fin donc le question du
rapporteur général donc la définition
des taux des taux variable c'est
certainement une bonne enfin une piste
intéressante
on ne méconnait pas la la difficulté
conceptuelle ne serait-ce que bon il
faut qu'on soit sûr de passer
l'étape du Conseil constitutionnel mais
l'idée de base
qui nous permet de de dire c'est dans
cette direction là qu'il faut aller
c'est aujourd'hui on est dans une
logique où il y a une réduction des DMTO
sur le neuf
et donc en fait la question c'est est-ce
que il faut pas inverser cette cette
logique voilà donc c'est ça je pense que
ça peut être
tout à fait
tout à fait considéré il faut évidemment
en analyser les les implications voir
les différents schémas possible mais en
tout cas c'est certainement une piste la
version de de la logique actuelle
sur les les travaux des administrations
vous a donné l'état de l'art
et donc on a quand même beaucoup
sollicité la Dhu P la DGCL
la DGFiP donc toutes les toutes les
administrations qui étaient en
première ligne on n'a pas de de de
réponse en réalité aujourd'hui si ce
n'est que finalement et ça me permet de
rebondir sur la sur la l'observation
initiale du de votre rapporteur spécial
monsieur blanc c'est
ça renvoie à la question des études
d'impact
l'étude d'impact tel qu'elle vous a été
présenté au moment où vous avez examiné
la loi c'était
dormi tranquille bonne journée
[Musique]
et la tendance elle revient en fait en
2031 à consommer 10 000 hectares
c'est-à-dire en fait d'avoir diminué
la consommation
sur la période
de en fait il faut économiser 60 000
hectares c'est-à-dire 6000 hectares par
an
on était sur une tendance en 2020 à 240
000 hectares et il faut passer à 180 000
hectares 6000 hectares par an finalement
on peut dire c'est pas grand chose à
l'échelle de l'ensemble sauf que
on tombe sur le poème mais qui qui va
faire l'effort
et donc quand on
prend un engagement
si on compte sur les autres pour faire
le travail c'est le voisin en
l'occurrence
à l'arrivée on a une situation où c'est
un peu comme
dans les Troyens de ripides le cœur dit
marchons marchons il reste immobile donc
en fait c'est c'est cette problématique
là donc ça renvoie à mon avis à deux
choses ça renvoie au fait que peut-être
il faut s'interroger sur la manière dont
sont faites les études d'impact puisque
en réalité ces études d'impact non qu'un
contrôle
préalable juridique fait par le Conseil
d'État puisque c'est la c'est la loi qui
l'a qui l'a décidé
donc peut-être qu'il faut aller qu'il
faut aller plus loin mais vous avez
exactement la même situation que c'est
pour ça qu'on évoquait les
problématiques de fiscalité
environnementale
que pour la taxe carbone la taxe carbone
d'un grand pas tout le monde a dit il
faut la voter c'était en 2018 et sauf
que notre rapport de 2019 a clairement
démontré que
c'était pas pareil pour chacun des
acteurs selon qu'ils étaient en ruralité
qu'ils avaient une contrainte automobile
qui avait ou non des transports
collectifs sur lesquels pouvaient
s'appuyer etc etc et donc en fait
l'enjeu c'est quand même bien de faire
des impacts mais de croire que
c'est quand même utile d'y aller c'est
qu'il y a différentes manières et le
fait que Monsieur l'emporteur général
vous vous évoquiez la possibilité que le
votre assemblée soit un peu le lieu de
réflexion ben oui je pense qu'il faut
une passer de descendant à l'ascendant
ça pour nous on est complètement
d'accord c'est en fait
ce pourquoi nous travaillons et on
travaille notamment avec l'idée selon
laquelle pour la fiscalité
comportementale il y a une réflexion il
y a une pédagogie à faire et donc tout
ça ne se fait pas en un
coup de baguette magique il faut il faut
pousser avant dernier
rapidement pour les autres points
la TASCOM voilà on pouvait pas le faire
mais il faut bien voir c'est que la S
comme c'est une problématique qui
impacte quand même très directement les
différentes composantes de la
distribution les problématiques
d'acteurs Amazon versus grande
distribution
commerçant le rôle du commerce en ligne
donc en fait cette ce sujet il faut le
le faire en étroite consultation avec
l'ensemble des acteurs de la profession
mais si vous utilisez la faculté qui est
la vôtre de nous saisir on pourra bien
sûr s'organiser pour y répondre
sur les
je pense avoir répondu à peu près à
toutes les questions
oui ça va vous allez avoir une deuxième
occasion vous allez voir ça va bien se
passer
alors on va commencer par Stéphane
sotarel suivi d'Antoine Lefebvre
oui merci monsieur le Président et merci
à la fois notre rapporteur spécial au
président
de CPO et du CPO pardon et à l'ensemble
de ceux qui ont travaillé sur le sujet
également à Valérie l'état bien sûr
puisque partager ici que la question des
ânes est là où l'une des préoccupations
prioritaires première de nos territoires
donc aujourd'hui des élus peut-être pas
encore effectivement comme ça a été
rappelé de la population avec des volets
juridiques bien sûr qui qui qui mérite
encore bien des travaux et des avancées
et le volet financier ou fiscalité que
vous nous avez présenté ce matin moi je
voulais insister sur un mot qui me
semble important et je reviendrai une ou
deux questions par rapport aux
propositions qui nous ont été faites et
au travail qui nous a été présenté et
dont je salue la la qualité et la
pertinence c'est le mot de
différenciation
que l'on peut aborder à la fois bien sûr
sur toute la dimension juridique de ce
dossier zan comme sur le dossier de la
fiscalité que vous avez que vous avez
abordé par ailleurs
j'avais en fait de deux questions une
sur le fait que au-delà bien sûr de la
compétence du Conseil des prélèvements
obligatoires cette question puisse être
traitée sur plus largement sur le
financement des collectivités
territoriales donc bien sûr avec le
volet fiscal mais aussi avec d'autres
volets de financement et en résonance
avec le rapport que nous a présenté la
Cour des comptes la semaine dernière en
particulier donc voir si cette dimension
là elle a été intégrée dans vos travaux
puisque vous y faites au moins référence
une fois sur les propositions liées à la
au DMTO et par ailleurs moi je voulais
insister sur un point qui aujourd'hui
est marginal mais qui permettrait une
approche plus positive que punitive de
de cette question c'est les fameuses
aménités rurales ou territoriales qui
aujourd'hui
ne pèse au sein de la DGF que 30
millions d'euros sauf erreur de ma part
et qui pourrait être incontestablement
un levier pour répondre à aux enjeux des
ânes et je voulais vous interroger sur
la perception que vous auriez et la
manière dont vous pensez que cette
dimension-là pourrait être activée soit
sur un plan fiscal soit sur un plan plus
large du financement je vous remercie
merci Stéphane j'ai à m'excusant j'ai
j'ai sauté involontairement Bernard
delcro donc je vais lui redonner la
parole avant Antoine Lefebvre
oui mais merci monsieur le Président et
merci pour ce rapport et les
interventions de nos collègues et
Jean-Baptiste blanc et Valérie Letard
alors juste d'abord moi je voudrais dire
que je partage tout à fait
le point de vue du président de la
commission des finances et ce ce qui se
passe ici ce sujet illustre parfaitement
le fait que on vote d'abord un texte on
se préoccupe après des conséquences et
souvent on est amené à venir colmater
des brèches voilà et je pense que au
moment où l'autre il faudra bien essayer
de mesurer les conséquences de ce qu'on
vote suffisamment en amont alors pour
revenir sur le sujet évidemment et on le
comprend votre apport et vos
propositions par du principe que le zan
est appliqué partout dans tous les
territoires de manière identique moi je
veux juste dire un préambule que mon
point de vue c'est que il doit être
appliqué de manière différenciée suivant
les territoires suivant les secteurs
urbains suivant les secteurs ruraux sauf
à vouloir con des territoires ruraux a
disparaître alors
et on est bien d'accord que évidemment
la question de la sobriété française
elle est réelle et qu'on doit avoir tout
cet objectif mais que les choses doivent
être appliquées de manière
différentielle sur la question de la
fiscalité
alors certes il y a un surcoût à
l'application d'usane il faut y apporter
des réponses pour ma part je ne suis pas
favorable à une taxe supplémentaire
spécifique zan il y a des réponses à
apporter peut-être par des
réorientations de fiscalité locale j'y
reviens pas vous vous l'avez dit par des
ciblages différents et à coup sûr par
des aides à l'investissement parce que
ça a très bien ça a été ça a été dit
l'investissement on a créé la
construction la création de logements
lorsqu'il s'agit de de d'acquérir de
réhabiliter ou de voir de démolir c'est
un coup bien supérieur à la construction
neuve donc je pense qu'il faut des des
réponses apportées au secours sur
les propositions qui sont faites
si on part du principe que les choses
s'appliquent
pensez-vous que vos propositions ou
l'ensemble de positions peuvent être
appliquées de manière identique encore
une fois en territoire urbain et en
territoire rural je pense par exemple à
la proposition numéro 4 qui est
intéressantes en elle-même sauf que la
question des friches la question des
zones déjà urbanisées des
artificialisées pardon déjà
artificialisé ne se pose pas du tout de
la même façon en milieu très urbain et
en milieu rural donc pensez-vous que ces
propositions peuvent être appliquées de
la même de la même façon et enfin
pourriez-vous nous préciser un peu
comment vous verriez la mise en oeuvre
de la proposition de façon un peu plus
concrète de la proposition numéro 6
merci Bernard chers collègues je vais
vous encourager à tenir vos questions
dans trois minutes à peu près
Antoine Lefebvre puis Sylvie ramillier
merci président et merci à Monsieur le
Président de CPO pour la présentation de
ce travail ainsi que la porte des de
notre rapporteur spécial et nos autres
rapporteurs alors sujet du Zen bien sûr
une interpelle de plus en plus et fait
craindre une fracture territoriale et à
la suite de Valérie Létard j'ai envie de
dire aussi que pour le moment un certain
nombre de nos concitoyens et une grande
partie des élus n'ont pas encore
conscience des conséquences réelles de
ce dispositif alors face à cette crainte
de la fracture territoriale j'aurais
plusieurs observations remarques et
questions d'abord un dispositif de
lissage fiscal entre les collectivités
par exemple la création ou la
réaffectation d'une part des ressources
fiscales ou bien la garantie d'une
réaffectation du large part de dotation
de l'État aux collectivités les moins
favorisées par dispositif serait il me
semble à minima une première étape pour
ne pas recréer cette fracture
territoriale et puis dans un deuxième
temps la rationalisation marche forcée
de l'urbanisation des territoires qui
est visé en quelque sorte par l'objectif
zan va incontestablement faire grimper
la valeur du foncier et la question à se
poser et jusqu'où et comment éviter dès
lors que la spéculation immobilière vous
foncière ne vienne se glisser dans les
appels d'offres et que finalement
l'objectif de sobriété foncière ne se
traduisent plus finalement que par un
très vaste marché spéculatif du foncier
constructible merci
Antoine Sylvie vermeiller puis Michel
Canevet
merci monsieur le Président je vais pas
être tellement force de proposition en
tout cas au sein de la commission des
finances mais je tiens à m'exprimer pour
dire moi je suis opposée aux ânes je
comprends pas pourquoi 0 cet objectif je
comprends pas le timing je trouve que
tout va très vite
je pense qu'on est peut-être passé d'une
artificialisation qui ressemblait à
n'importe quoi aujourd'hui plus rien du
tout je trouve que ça va trop vite donc
je suis opposé à toute évolution fiscale
à partir du moment où on sait pas d'amis
d'accord sur l'objectif et puis la
définition de la trajectoire il y a deux
ans personne ne savait ce que c'était
que le zan et aujourd'hui artificialisé
c'est devenu un crime
je sais pas je pense que on va mettre en
mouvement une révolte au sein des
territoires ruraux surtout elle est bien
partie
et donc je pense que c'est très
prématuré je suis heureuse d'avoir
d'être éclairé sur les propositions et
ce qui pourrait se passer mais pour
l'instant
zan quand on prononça dans un territoire
rural enfin moi pour ceux que je connais
c'est devenu une bombe c'est explosif on
s'entend pas sur rien du tout
tout simplement parce que la liberté
d'administrer c'est quand même un droit
constitutionnel aménager son territoire
c'est aussi un droit réel pour les
collectivités et là on est en train de
le retirer ce droit qui est essentiel le
droit à vivre dans les territoires
le droit à vivre dans un territoire où
on est né on est en train de le nier et
donc je m'excuse ça n'a rien à voir avec
la commission des finances mais c'est
quelque chose de fondamental et qui
devient absolument subversif donc je
comprends pas au nom de quoi on va
fermer des territoires à l'accueil de
population
euh je il y a quelque chose de de très
fondamental de très profond sur lequel
on n'a pas suffisamment réfléchi et puis
au fond bien sûr je suis favorable à des
mesures qui vont encourager la sobriété
foncière etc mais je ne partage pas
l'idée que en recyclant des friches on
va dégager suffisamment de marge de
manœuvre pour accueillir la population
et qu'il puisse vivre
dans avec plaisir dans des territoires
je crois que le
la solution là elle est trop simpliste
en plus à quel coup effectivement
parce que recycler des friches qui sont
pleines d'amiante ça fait sortir des
prix au mètre carré qui sont délirants
par rapport à au prix du mètre carré
d'un lotissement classique donc je suis
même pas un moment donné on va dire mais
ça coûte cher effectivement enfin on n'a
pas encore mis ça en perspective et puis
évidemment on a ces injonctions
contradictoires zéro artificialis oui on
est tous d'accord pour consommer moins
de foncier mais on a aussi des
injonctions de relocalisation des
industries de d'accueil de population
etc tout ça est absolument
contradictoire et donc voilà je
fais partie des gens absolument
perplexes sur le zan je tiens à le dire
et je n'ai pas beaucoup de propositions
à faire à cette heure mais je trouve que
le débat il est bien loin d'avoir été
conduit sur l'objectif et encore plus
sur la trajectoire merci
merci
Sylvie plus pour un coup de gueule que
pour une question si j'ai bien compris
je suis pas sûr que le président du CPO
puisse réellement répondre à votre
question peut-être que la mission
conjointe elle fera amener une réflexion
plus large sur ce point
Michel dans la même veine c'est leur
travail mené par le Conseil des
prélèvements obligatoires de sera
certainement très utile pour bien
appréhender cette question extrêmement
importante du zan alors moi j'ai deux
questions sur le les recommandations
d'abord sur la recommandation numéro une
sur la taxe sur les logements vacants
pourquoi est-ce que vous ne l'entendez
pas à tous les toutes les communes
françaises pourquoi simplement supprimer
le critère des communes de du nombre
d'habitants de 50000
moi je pense que ça concerne tout le
territoire national et qu'il faut que
cette taxe puisse être institué à la
diligence des conseils municipaux sur
l'ensemble du territoire premièrement
deuxièmement la recommandation numéro 7
sur les DMT
alors il faut faire attention c'est une
bonne idée de confissant aux communes
mais il faut faire attention aux
disparités de financement je veux dire
par là qu'il y a des communes où les
dmteo amènent des sommes considérables
tout simplement parce que des maisons se
bandent à des prix élevés souvent ce
sont des communes d'ailleurs où il y a
beaucoup de résidences scandales donc
beaucoup de taxes foncières donc déjà
beaucoup de richesses et donc il faudra
encore trouver à critère de pondération
pour faire en sorte que tout le monde
puisse bénéficier de cette manière il
faut y réfléchir
merci Michel Charles Gonnet puis Vincent
Segouin
si monsieur le Président oui je ne
reviendrai pas sur les problèmes
techniques dont nous ne sommes qu'à
l'aube simplement n'hésitez pas à parler
un peu plus fort dans le micro ok je ne
reviendrai pas sur les problèmes
techniques qui ne sont qu'à
le ciment mais j'ajouterai simplement
une réflexion et je voudrais ajouter aux
observations du président et du
rapporteur général pour souligner le
rôle du Sénat dans les travaux qui
deviennent produire durant ce mois et
quelque part leur complémentarité je
veux évoquer le rapport de la Cour des
comptes sur les scénarios des finances
des collectivités locales dont on a
parlé et je crois que ce rapport
au delà du Zen ajoute
et introduit la dimension
environnementale qui qui lui manquait et
ça soulève à la fois des problèmes
d'équité territoriale on a on l'a dit
mais aussi le rapport de la fiscalité et
du droit au comportement comme on vient
de l'entendre et je pense que grâce à
l'expertise et initiative de
Jean-Baptiste blanc et au travail de CPO
tout ça dépasse largement l'étude
d'impact qui nous manquait pour apporter
vraiment de la matière à
la refonte de la fiscalité locale qui de
toute façon est inéluctable et quand
même pas devenir proche car je pense que
le système actuel que qui a quand même
plus d'un demi-siècle et devenu
totalement obsolète avec toutes les
réformes que nous venons de subir et
encore celles qui se prépare
merci CHARLES VINCENT Segoin puis Daniel
Bruyer
oui merci Monsieur Brison alors moi je
m'allie vraiment à propos de sa vie de
Sylvie Vernier moi je suis pareil
exactement dans le même étage je n'ai
pas encore mesuré toutes les
conséquences d'une telle loi et je pense
que tout le monde ne s'en rend pas
compte
et que ça va poser des problèmes lourds
et avec sûrement encore un avis des mers
qui qui vont penser que
toute compétence leur échappe et que ils
n'ont plus de d'avenir sur la politique
de leur ville ou de leur village
alors je reviens dans les finances
l'objectif essentiel c'est de
transformer des friches pour les rendre
habitables alors ça part d'un bon
sentiment ça c'est clair mais forcément
il va y avoir un coup de traitement
supplémentaire ce coût de traitement
supplémentaire va augmenter le prix de
revient du bien et où le prix de
location du bien et on risque encore
d'avoir des investisseurs qui vont se
détourner de de territoires ruraux parce
que la rentabilité ne sera pas au
rendez-vous donc j'imagine que ça ça
sera compensé ses coûts de traitement
par de l'argent public comme on sait si
bien faire avec de la dette
qu'en est-il exactement moi j'ai besoin
qu'on m'écrire sur le sujet
j'ai un deuxième point
on parlait tout à l'heure j'ai écouté
des rapporteurs qui nous disaient que il
y a des terrains bien sûr qui vont qui
étaient constructives qui vont être
déclassés donc non constructibles avec
de la perte de valeur
donc ça me saoulait deux points
financiers sur ces terrains
il y a une fiscalité qui a été appliquée
en tant que terrain constructible
qu'en études quid quand ce terrain se
trouve
déclassé est-ce qu'il va y avoir un
remboursement de ce surplus de fiscalité
qui a pu être prélevé je pense notamment
aussi à l'IFI ça peut être de l'IFI et
puis la deuxième question c'est est-ce
qu'il y a encore un apport d'argent
public pour compenser des pertes pour
les personnes merci
merci Vincent Daniel Breuillet merci
monsieur le Président et merci de ce
rapport très éclairant pour ma part la
question qui me paraît centrale c'est
celle de la valorisation des aménités
naturelles vous mentionnez rural je
pense personnellement je mettrai naturel
parce que le même problème se pose dans
les métropoles aussi j'avais publié un
article qui disait la métropole sera
Vertou invivable et qui soulignait que
la nature ne paye pas de droit à
construire quand le bâti en paye et que
ça se traduit par beaucoup d'arbitrage
par exemple la métropole du Grand Paris
a quand même un tout petit périmètre a
quand même consommé 1600 hectares dans
les 20 dernières années sur un périmètre
aussi petit et donc Lausanne c'est
certes une question rurale c'est aussi
une question je pense pour les
métropoles si on veut
revaloriser la vivabilité moi je voulais
dire mon soutien aux réflexions menées
sur les DMTO je m'interrogeais s'il n'y
a pas d'autres pistes je pense par
exemple à des à des niveaux de TVA
différents parce que bien sûr
reconstruire sur l'existant à un coût
supplémentaire à construire nulle part
mais je pense qu'il faudrait joindre à
nos réflexions le coût de ces
artificalisations
excessive alors parfois on le mesure
très facilement quand il s'agit
d'inondation de catastrophes on peut le
mesurer de façon moins visible quand on
pense au rapport de l'IPES par exemple
sur l'effondrement du vivant sur la
disparition d'espèces etc qui sont des
choses dont on se dit toujours que c'est
pas très grave jusqu'au moment où ça
atteint des niveaux qui remettent en
cause la qualité de vie que nous avons
et puis enfin je dis je pense qu'il y a
forcément des réponses différenciées
selon la situation
des communes quand elles sont très
rurales ou très urbaines moi je voudrais
rappeler que j'avais suggéré que ce soit
au fond la promotion immobilière qui
finance la renaturation de la ville
quand on parle de la métropole du dans
Paris j'avais même suggéré que tout
projet immobilier fasse l'objet d'une
taxe enfin d'une taxe face l'objet d'une
contribution en hauteur de 5% de son
budget pour la renaturation et j'avais
eu la surprise d'être auditionné par
deux grands promoteurs immobiliers qui
au lieu de me jeter des pierres m'avait
dit que mes réflexions les intéressait
ça c'est très inquiétant
donc
excusez-moi je suis en aide enregistré
je devrais pas
peut-être Valérie quelques avant de
redonner la parole au président quelques
minutes
très rapidement pour pour dire
qu'effectivement
ce que les uns et les autres expriment
sur l'inquiétude qui remonte des
territoires parce que vous êtes au
quotidien avec les mers c'est bien ce
qui fait l'objet de la mission qui a été
décidé par le Sénat de façon
complètement transc commission puisque
c'est quatre commissions qui sont à
l'initiative de cette mission commune de
contrôle et c'est bien parce que on a
conscience que telle que la loi est
arrivée et que les décrets sont sortis
parce que vous l'avez rappelé les uns
les autres les décrire interrogent aussi
sur la en tout cas dans le cadre de leur
définition sur le fait que pour certains
aspects ils vont bien au-delà de ce qui
est sorti de la commission mixte
paritaire et qu'on pouvait s'interroger
aussi de ce point de vue là et donc nous
c'est évidemment de voir comment au
travers de toutes les toutes les
auditions que nous menons on en entend
des choses chers collègues on peut
effectivement revoir les choses pour que
une loi qui a été adoptée aujourd'hui
elle ne soit pas complètement aux
antipodes de ce que les territoires
aspirent pouvoir faire pour atteindre un
objectif que tout le monde peut partager
simplement sur la méthode personne s'y
retrouve et c'est vraiment cette
question de méthode sur laquelle nous
essayons de travailler trouver des voies
de passage comme Jean-Baptiste blanc l'a
rappelé je pense que le gouvernement à
tous les échelons a pris conscience
quand même aussi de la percussion qu'il
y a entre cette loi qui a été adoptée et
toutes les lois que nous examinons en
parallèle ça aussi on le sent bien celle
qui est à l'ordre du jour en ce moment
ENR et le zan ça s'interroge donc
aujourd'hui on voit bien c'est ce qui a
été dit par les uns les autres doit
avancer on doit réfléchir mais le Sénat
a aujourd'hui un travail déterminant à
pour justement poser des curseurs sur
des enjeux que tout le monde
relève quand on entend dans les
territoires c'est le projet le problème
des grands projets d'intérêt nationaux
c'est le problème de la temporalité car
lorsqu'on regarde même dans la
restitution effectivement de la copie
des schémas régionaux d'aménagement du
territoire vous savez que les
conférences des Scott ont remis leur
copie le 22 octobre que les conférences
donc des scottes terminées les régions
doivent effectivement bouclés leur
travail en tout cas avoir arrêté
complètement la procédure pour février
2024 mais ce qui veut dire concrètement
et c'est ce qu'on a bien compris au
travers de nos auditions qu'avec les
consultations des personnes publiques
associées ça veut dire fin février 2023
on ferme le banc parce qu'il y a un an
de consultation ça veut dire que le
travail de consultation entre les
régions et les collectivités s'arrête en
mars donc toutes ces questions de délai
de temporalité nous les questions de
moyens vous l'avez dit un fond vert de 2
milliards d'euros est-ce qu'on a évalué
le besoin réel
en termes de requalification des
richesses qui eu des études d'impact
là-dessus est-ce qu'on sait si ça
correspond besoin quand on entend les
uns et les autres on voit bien que on
doute quand même de la capacité de ce
fond aller jusqu'à ce qui est nécessaire
d'obtenir pour pouvoir aller requalifier
et fait reconstruire la vie sur la ville
ou d'accompagner même la ruralité on
voit bien que la question de
l'ingénierie aussi pour accompagner ces
transformations elle est aussi elle
interroge aussi on comprend aussi que la
gouvernance est un sujet à tous les
étages de mise en oeuvre d'usane et que
cette gouvernance elle est aussi
déterminante pour la réussite de ce
projet la ruralité le littoral les zones
de montagne l'outre-mer font valoir
aussi que on ne peut pas avoir un
exercice unique et commun toutes ces
questions c'est celle là que nous
réinterrogeons mais on avait besoin que
la commission des finances fasse ce
qu'elle a fait avec le CPO c'est
essentiel c'est de connaître le champ
des possibles de voir comment on peut
explorer et encore une fois c'était
absolument essentiel qu'on est ce
travail à ce moment qui malheureusement
n'a pas été fait en amont
merci madame la Présidente je vais vous
donner la parole président Lefa pour
répondre rapidement à l'ensemble des
interrogations qui d'ailleurs souvent se
recoupe bien entendu c'est assez logique
je vais vous en mettre une petite
dernière manière juste d'agacer
est-ce que est-ce qu'un mécanisme de
droit artificialisé pour les communes
c'est quelque chose qui a du sens c'est
à dire comme le droit polluer d'une
certaine façon une des communes aurait
un droit artificialisé qui serait
revendable ne négociable entre commune
etc est-ce que ça a du sens où est-ce
que c'est complètement délirant
[Musique]
le problème pour pas se situer au niveau
de la de la commune c'est nécessairement
un niveau supra supra régional parce que
si c'est dans le même dans le périmètre
d'une grande région ça paraît ça paraît
en fait c'est compliqué donc
c'est un sujet mais c'était pas notre
commande et donc on a on n'a pas pu le
traiter
sur le zan et pour nous évidemment une
un objectif donc il est dans la loi on
va pas le discuter simplement je voulais
appeler votre attention sur les
développements de la page 17 du rapport
qui montre que il y a effectivement
plusieurs problématiques à l'oeuvre donc
il y a un certain nombre de d'objectifs
volontaristes qui vont contribuer en
fait à la pression immobilière c'est
évidemment l'agriculture les objectifs
de souveraineté alimentaire c'est aussi
l'énergie l'objectif de de d'augmenter
la part des énergies en ouvrables
c'est aussi la réindustrialisation la
nécessité de développer des zones des
zones d'activité mais à contrario
les études de l'Insee nous montrent et
notamment les dernières celles qui ont
fait les chiffrages à 2050 et 2070
montre que là où on était dans les
précédentes de projections autour de en
2050 de 74 millions d'habitants en fait
on descend à 69 millions ce qui veut
donc dire que la croissance
démographique
oblige il y a un ralentissement
prévisible alors qui ne va évidemment
pas se répartir sur l'ensemble du
territoire de la manière mais mais c'est
une composante et que donc les
composantes les plus fortes sur le
besoin de futurs de logement c'est le
vieillissement de la population
alors que croissance démographique et
des cohabitations liées à l'augmentation
des des séparations et à la mise en
couple de plus en plus tardive
auront sans doute un effet plus modéré
et donc ça montre aussi évidemment que
les aires d'attraction des villes vont
concentrer dans la plupart des régions
l'essentiel des besoins futurs donc ça
c'est pour montrer si vous voulez que ça
ne veut pas du tout dire que c'est les
communes rurales qui vont être la
variable d'ajustements ça n'a pas de ça
n'a pas de sens on voit bien qu'il y a
des enjeux je demande d'aménagement du
territoire qui a des projets d'intérêt
national enfin il y a beaucoup de choses
qui rentrent en ligne de compte et qui
montrent que la négociation des des
schémas directeurs et est essentiel
alors sur
les
l'observation qui était faite sur la
recommandation numéro 1 pourquoi est-ce
qu'on ne les tend pas toutes les
communes
en fait c'est constitutionnellement pas
possible parce que il faut tenir compte
des zones sous tension et toutes les
communes ne sont pas en zone sous
tension
donc on peut pas dire on va généraliser
à l'ensemble des des communes il faut
que le critère tension sur sur les
logements vacants puissent puissent
s'exprimer
sur les sur les DMTO
il y a effectivement à réfléchir
à l'ensemble des conséquences à la fois
pour la fiscalité locale pour la
fiscalité
individuelle
puisque il y a effectivement des enjeux
de de valorisation ou de dépréciation
donc qui prend en charge cela derrière
il y a quand même le débat qui est
la question du
taux de rendement des propriétés
foncières non bâtie et donc on a un
rendement en fait de ses propriétés
foncières non-batiques qui est faible
qui est qui renvoie la problématique du
statut de fermage et donc c'est un sujet
effectivement très important qu'il faut
qu'il faut appréhender donc il y a un
sujet qu'il faut traiter évidemment en
liaison avec les parties prenantes
principales qui sont les éditeurs et
aussi l'idée selon laquelle
j'aurais être contribué à l'écosystème
ça une rémunération c'est c'est justifié
et donc il faut pouvoir voir comment ça
peut être appréhendé pour les acteurs
concernés mais aussi pour la fiscalité
voilà donc ça c'est quelque chose qui à
mon sens devra être traité de manière
plus
plus plus générale voilà je sais pas si
mes collègues vous voulez ajouter
peut-être merci monsieur le Président
sur le lien avec le rapport réalisé par
la Cour sur le financement des
collectivités effectivement le sujet de
la dimension de la transition écologique
avait été intégrée pas Lausanne en
particulier mais la question de la
transition écologique la Cour avait
notamment proposé le fait de faire
remonter un certain nombre de fiscalité
écologique qui aujourd'hui relève des
régions au niveau de l'État pour que
cette réforme là puisse avoir lieu
indépendamment de sujets de compensation
la cour n'avait pas été jusqu'à regarder
chacune des politiques publiques type
Lausanne et c'est typiquement via ce
type de rapport qu'on peut prolonger la
réflexion il y avait également un autre
point commun entre ce rapport et et le
présent à Port c'était sur la question
des critères de répartition
la Cour a pointé notamment le fait que à
la fois les critères actuels de
répartition des dotations étaient datées
devenu illisibles et que dans un mode de
financement où les impôts nationaux
transférés aux
collectivités prenez une place
importante la question des critères de
répartition prenez également une place
importante et que le fait de répartir en
compensant à l'euro une dynamique passée
pouvait compléter donc cette question
autour des critères avait été identifié
et donc pour répondre à une question de
quel pourrait être ces critères ils sont
inventés aujourd'hui qu'ils mettent de
voirie rentre dans les critères de
répartition si demain on tenait compte
des espaces naturels qui sont entretenus
par les villes si on tenait compte des
parcs et jardins voilà donc ça ce sont
des critères inventés voilà il est un
peu le point entre les deux et puis pour
ce qui est de la différenciation qui a
été abordée le premier sujet
différenciation ce sera dans la
répartition des des droits
artificialisés donc ça c'est ça relève
plutôt de la gouvernance et dans ce
rapport la question de la
différenciation on l'a abordé en
essayant d'avoir une palette d'outils la
plus ouverte laissée à disponibilité des
mers on envisage d'ailleurs dans le
corps du rapport le lancement d'un
groupe de travail pour vraiment écouter
les maires sur les besoins additionnels
mais encore une fois en laissant la main
au maximum aux élus et aux exécutifs
locaux sur les impôts dont ils dispos
très bien merci merci monsieur le
Président merci Madame merci messieurs
de votre venue merci madame la
Présidente de la de la mission conjointe
bonne fin de journée à tous